hello YouTube friends welcome to Table
Talk my name is Brett pastor at the
table and as I mentioned in my last
episode for years I was terrible at
praying but eventually something worked
for me and it's honestly not something
I'd ever heard much about in my
evangelical wing of the Christian Church
so what was it one word
silence for a season I stopped saying
words when I prayed and I began to
simply sit in silence I personally
engaged a practice called centering
prayer which at some point I'll do some
other episodes on to unpack its mean
pretty straightforward basically you are
simply quiet and you focus your mind on
that still point within yourself which i
think is really the same thing is just
saying you're you're tuned into the
Spirit of God within and then when you
find your mind wandering and you will
you simply return to God so that's what
I did and this practice taught me a few
things first first it taught me to focus
what is everyone's complaint about
prayer I can't focus my my mind it just
won't stay in one place of course a form
of silent prayer like I just described
above what does it do it begins to teach
you to focus now does that mean that my
mind is now like a steel trap in that it
never wanders no I still have a long way
to go but each day I get just a little
bit better sight know there is good
neuroscience on this that says yes
indeed the brain can be trained to focus
and yes this is a skill that will
translate to the rest of your life in
positive ways so that's the first thing
focus second it taught me to relax
when I wanted to run here's what I mean
to be human is to find ourselves bumping
up against uncomfortable experiences
sensations feelings and emotions and
when we feel those things we really
really want to escape them we don't want
to face them we don't want to
acknowledge them but we want to run from
them
is the restlessness an endless craving
that drives each one of us the brilliant
French philosopher and Christian Blaise
Pascal he put it this way he said all of
humanity's problems stemmed from man's
inability to sit quietly in a room alone
that's a really profound insight because
I mean if you think about it so much of
our lives is characterized by this
Restless avoidance and addiction right
we don't want to go home to face like
our marriage and so what we do we work
late or go out drinking or watch a movie
right we don't want to do work and so we
turn to Facebook we don't want to face
our pain we don't we can't do that and
so what do we do well we turn to
substances to help us go right we can't
deal with our memories and so we numb
them through endless romantic
relationships or TV binge watching and
so on and so forth we can't sit quietly
in a room alone so coming back to silent
prayer it has taught me and continues to
teach me to simply sit there it's sort
of the opposite of that old phrase don't
just sit there
do something so I'd say don't just do
something sit there see our problem is
that we can't just sit there
but we must sit there we must learn to
face it to face ourselves and when it
gets boring well we just sit there and
when we get uncomfortable we just sit
there and sometimes we have an amazing
God experience but we just sit there and
other times it feels like nothing is
happening this is not working
Brett is a lying liar but just sit there
see silent prayer really is the opposite
of addiction because we relax and we
turn to God instead of run third it laid
the groundwork for more classical forms
of prayer
see some of you may be wondering it solo
it is all you do sit in silence what
what about praying with words man what
about the Lord's Prayer for goodness
sake yes eventually my season of nothing
but silence came to an end but what I
found is that I now had the heartbeat of
prayer which is presence I was learning
to be present to God and now I could
pray the Lord's Prayer with greater
focus and presence now I could pray for
others with greater focus in presence
and in fact that's my practice to this
day I take time for prayer with words
and then about the same amount of time
for a prayer of silent meditation with
Christ so if you've had trouble learning
to pray to engage this sort of practice
perhaps it's time that you introduced a
time of silence well that's all for
today if you enjoyed this video please
like it share it comment and subscribe
to my youtube channel by searching
bretzel fir'd hey Grayson peace